es geht manchmal aber nicht nur ums Herz
sondern auch ums Geld sorry
ein riesiges Vermögen das ist klar ne
und die Frage wer wer kriegt all das
nämlich worum geht's da um Reichtümer um
Geld ganz pragmatische Form vieles
andere praktische Sachen also eine ganze
Shoppingmeile in London kann man zum
Beispiel haben oder auch Sachen die man
vielleicht nicht so braucht Krustentiere
an der schottischen Küste
Queen Elizabeth II hinterlässt nicht nur
viele Titel Hunde und Ämter sondern auch
ein umfangreiches Vermögen Ländereien
und Immobilien sie ist die wohl
bekannteste Einkaufsstraße im Königreich
die Regent Street gehört genauso wie
Windsor Castle und anderen Immobilien
dem Crown es Tate der eigenen
Immobilienfirma der britischen
Königsfamilie dazu kommen knapp 120.000
Hektar Land eine Fläche so groß wie
Hamburg und Bremen zusammen außerdem
gehört jeder Fleck Erde im Land der
keinen anderweitigen Besitzer hat dem
Crown es Tate und kurioserweise alle
wilden Krustentiere in Schottland ob die
da Mitspracherecht haben Buckingham
Palace Kensington Palace das Herzogtum
Cornwall sowie Lancaster verwaltet die
Royal firm also die Königsfamilie selbst
sie bestehen nach dem Tod von Queen
Elizabeth II aus 7 Personen König
Charles III seiner Frau Camilla Prinz
William und seiner Frau Kate Elisabeths
Tochter Prinzessin and sowie Elisabeth
jüngsten Sohn Prinz Edward und seiner
Frau Sophie zusammen verwalten Sie einen
megaunternehmen geschätzter Wert 8
Milliarden Euro die größte
Einnahmequelle der Tourismus der Erlös
aus offiziellen Auftritten und auch
Merchandise Artikeln mit Aufdrucken der
Mitgliedern der Königsfamilie Wappen
oder ähnlichen bekommt die Royal firm
und das lohnt sich meistens auch Johnny
Walker Whisky konnte durch das
königliche Wappen die Verkäufer um 10%
steigern doch damit nicht genug die
private Perth zu deutsch geheime
Geldbörse besteht aus weiteren 20.000
Hektar so groß wie Stuttgart und 306
Kilometern Küstenlinie die der
Königsfamilie gehören die jährlichen
Einnahmen von zuletzt 24 Millionen Euro
pro Jahr gehen direkt an den Monarchen
und dann ist da ja auch noch das
ist der Vermögen der Queen zum hör
Matches Tees Personal Ersatz zählen zum
Beispiel ihre Kunstsammlung wertvolle
Briefmarken Juwelen inklusive der
Königskrone die beiden Schlösser
belmoral und zenringham House außerdem
ihre geliebten Tiere Hunde Rennpferde
und auch alle Schwäne auf der Themse die
nicht markiert sind haben der Queen
gehört wer was erbt steht in ihrem
Testament ist aber noch nicht klar
anzunehmen ist dass der Großteil der
Besitztümer im Wert von 500 Millionen
Euro an Charles übergehen wird und das
völlig steuerfrei denn damit der Monarch
von Generation zu Generation nicht immer
ärmer wird hat Queen Elizabeth II die
40-prozentige Erbschaftssteuer für die
Königsfamilie abgeschafft
[Musik]